bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sensublique votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportages on est ensemble tous les
jours du lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h
avec nos invités experts les
éditorialistes les journalistes de la
rédaction de Public Sénat pour donner du
sens à l'actualité et voici le sommaire
de ce 3 octobre Donald Trump face à la
menace judiciaire l'ancien président
assiste depuis hier à son procès civil
il est accusé d'avoir surévalué la
valeur de son empire pour tromper ses
partenaires financiers banque assurance
et autres le milliardaire hurle au
complot politique il risque surtout une
amende gigantesque de l'argent qui
pourrait lui manquer pour sa campagne
électorale elle est de plus en plus
présente dans nos bureaux et autres
espaces de coworking l'intelligence
artificielle dite générative bouleverse
déjà le monde du travail
l'intelligence artificielle est vraiment
la méga tendance déterminante pour les
10 prochaines années au moins et
l'intelligence artificielle générative a
vraiment remodeler notre façon de voir
les choses nous voyons que chaque
produit chaque service chaque entreprise
dans le monde sera impacté par
l'intelligence artificielle la
technologie évolue en fait plus vite que
tout ce que j'ai pu voir jusqu'à présent
après les métiers manuels remplacés par
des machines lia va-t-elle détruire
aussi des centaines de millions
d'emplois dans le monde dans les bureaux
et puis aussi dans l'industrie créative
en en débat dans trois quarts d'heure
mais d'abord donc retour sur la première
journée d'audience du procès Trump à New
York ou quand un ancien président
transforme la salle d'audience en
tribune médiatique Cécile sixo il
n'était pas obligé de se présenter
devant la cour mais en pleine campagne
présidentielle pour 2024 Donald Trump a
voulu faire de son procès une tribune
devant les caméras l'ancien président
américain a dénoncé
un simulacre de justice et se dit
victime de persécution politique pour
l'empêcher de revenir à la Maison
Blanche
c'est une tentative de Menuires lors
d'une élection cela ne s'est jamais
produit auparavant qu'un président des
États-Unis quitte ses fonctions et
souhaite inculper c'est moi qui suis
victime d'un crime parce que nous avons
un procureur de compter corrompu mais
aussi une procureur général corrompue
corrompu Donald Trump qualifie également
la procureur général de New York
Laetitia James de raciste présente dans
la salle c'est elle qui a mené l'enquête
elle accuse Donald Trump et ses deux
fils de fraude il aurait triché sur la
valeur de son patrimoine immobilier dans
les années 2010 et obtenu des prêts
avantageux grâce à cela quel que soit
votre pouvoir quel que soit l'argent que
vous pensez détenir personne n'est
au-dessus de la loi et il est de ma
responsabilité de mon devoir et de mon
travail de la faire respecter la loi est
à la fois puissante et fragile et
aujourd'hui au tribunal nous trouverons
nos arguments et la justice va prévaloir
si dans ce procès Donald Trump ne risque
pas la prison il pourrait bien perdre
une partie de son empire économique dans
l'État de New York notamment et payer
jusqu'à 250 millions d'euros de pénalité
en revanche 4 procès pénal l'attendent
l'an prochain pour complot contre l'État
il risque dans ce cas de la prison ferme
ce procès peut-il peser sur la campagne
électorale on en débat tout de suite
avec Elisa shell bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes professeur de sciences politiques à
l'Université Paris Nanterre et
rédactrice en chef de la revue politique
américaine Jean-Claude Beaujour bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous êtes à vos cas
spécialiste des États-Unis les services
politiques bonsoir Laetitia bienvenue on
attend Anne désigne dans DC quelques
minutes un chiffre tient pour pour
ouvrir ce débat c'est un procès qui
pourrait coûter cher financièrement à
Donald Trump il encourt déjà une amende
de 250 millions de dollars elisachell on
va peut-être on vient de le voir avec
avec notre sujet d'ouverture mais
rentrer un peu dans le détail de de ce
qui lui reprocher à lui et à deux de ses
fils jugés donc au civils c'est quoi
c'est une fraude en quelque sorte dont
il est dont il est accusé oui tout à
fait c'est une forme de fraude il a
surestimé la valeur où ils ont surestimé
la valeur de leur patrimoine il y a une
dizaine d'années pour obtenir des prêts
et des assurances de prêt à des tarifs
plus avantageux on estime pour l'heure
qui l'aurait gagné de cette manière cent
millions de dollars donc c'est une somme
conséquente et c'est aujourd'hui pour
cela qu'il est jugé alors c'est
intéressant parce que là je parlais
d'une amende de potentiel de 250
millions de dollars Jean-Claude
bourgeois est-ce que d'abord il faut que
la justice fasse son travail etc etc on
va essayer de pas trop brûler les étapes
dans ce débat mais est-ce que cet argent
parce que c'est l'une des thématiques
pourrait lui manquer dans le cadre d'une
campagne une campagne électorale
américaine qui par définition coûtent
très cher alors bien sûr venez dire la
campagne
présidentielle coûte excessivement cher
et que lorsqu'on doit financer des spots
publicitaires surtout dans le dernier
mois où on bombarde un peu partout on se
déplace on se déplace des équipes parce
qu'il y a derrière aussi des équipes
vous savez autour d'une campagne
présidentielle il y a beaucoup de
professionnels ça se professionne c'est
beaucoup plus professionnel que que chez
nous en Europe donc il faut payer ce
monde payer les sondages donc ça coûte
beaucoup d'argent cela étant il y a
malgré tout une nuance c'est que pendant
ces procès notamment ce procès qui va
commencer on parle de plusieurs semaines
de de process qui veut dire que Donald
Trump va occuper l'espace médiatique car
la différence du système continental
l'instruction la fameuse instruction se
fait à l'audience et donc nous aurons de
très très longues audiences sur toute
une journée avec des caméras avec donc
tout cela il va occuper l'espace
médiatique et ça ce n'est pas négligé
même si il sera sans doute pas il va pas
être présent à tous les audiences tous
les jours mais là on a déjà vu sur les
deux premiers jours c'est une tribune
mais c'est avant tout une marque donc le
seul fait que ce soit son procès et bien
il sera question tout le monde aura à la
bouche Donald Trump ça sera probablement
l'un des procès les plus médiatiques de
la décennie aussi peut-être qu'il
voulait et Donald Trump que ce soit
filmé ce procès et ça n'a pas été
finalement accepté cette requête il ne
sera pas filmé Donald Trump il tenait
pourquoi pour parler bien sûr à son camp
à cet extracteurs qui sont accros pas de
sortir régulièrement il y aura les
sorties d'audience et puis il y aura la
couverture médiatique de toutes les
façons qui se fera alors je propose à
désigne de nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
elle est juste juste à bien bienvenue à
vous installez-vous tranquillement vous
êtes professeur des universités juristes
et on va en profiter pour citer votre
livre bonsoir bienvenue à vous votre
livre les États-Unis et la démocratie
livre publié aux éditions
l'Harmattan forcément j'avais plein de
questions pour vous aussi on vient de de
démarrer vous nous entendiez là derrière
les coulisses sur le les enjeux on va
dire financiers de de ce procès aussi
bien est-ce que ça pourrait obliger
Donald Trump qui est quand même
richissime à vendre par exemple il y a
cette Trump Tower là cet immeuble qui
est emblématique est-ce que il pourrait
en arriver là alors il est très embêté
par les procès au pénal mais ça ça
frappe au coeur aux porte-monnaie c'est
son empire Trump et à la fois sur le
financiers il faut savoir qu'il n'a plus
le droit d'exercer ni ses fils dans
l'État de New York donc quelque part il
va falloir mettre le siège ailleurs ça
c'est une conséquence de ce procès
judgement ou le juge a dit il y a
fraudes c'est même pas la peine qu'on
fasse le procès sur la fraude elle est
avérée parce que la surévaluation elle
est chiffrée selon les cas entre 800
millions de dollars ou 2,2 milliards de
dollars donc quand on a des chiffres
comme ça ça ne peut pas être une
coïncidence ça ne peut pas être juste
une petite erreur de temps en temps il y
a une fraude avérée et donc le juge
enfin ce que cherche Laetitia James la
ministre de la Justice ou la procureur
c'est à dire elle est au sommet du
judiciaire de l'État de New York et donc
c'est elle qui poursuit en l'occurrence
sauf que c'est pas du pénal donc elle a
diligé en T7 enquête d'ailleurs à cause
de Michael Cohen qui va témoigner c'est
lui qui a divulgué que Trump tricher
faisait ses surévaluation
ancien
etc et là ça va être très intéressant
lorsqu'il va témoigner les questions qui
vont être posées et la
contre-examination par la défense oui
alors il peut être amené à vendre parce
que il a l'interdiction de faire des
transactions immobilières dans l'État de
New York pendant 5 ans il va de toute
façon voilà bien d'accord il va devoir
payer 250 millions de dollars de
restitution de dédommagement mais là le
procès qui se déroule c'est pour le
moment on est ce qu'ils appellent civil
en américain c'est du commerce du
commerce droit des affaires mais
semblerait que il y ait sans doute des
infractions de nature pénale le fait que
pour faire ces surévaluation il est
falsifié les comptes par exemple
elisachell on l'a dit il assiste en tout
cas aux deux premiers jours de de son
procès à notre sujet d'ouverture c'était
sur la première journée d'audience mais
là on a des images en cette fin
d'après-midi qui nous arrive de de la
deuxième journée alors il y a une
volonté médiatique d'occuper le terrain
on l'a bien compris mais est-ce qu'il y
a aussi une crainte juridique d'après
vous dans l'esprit de Donald Trump et de
ses défenseurs s'il est là c'est aussi
pour ça ce qu'on peut dire ça je dirais
que s'il est là c'est principalement
qu'il a besoin d'argent parce que les
frais de justice sont sont très élevés
il a déjà à travers ses fonds de
campagne engagés 65 millions de dollars
depuis janvier et 2021 là on parle de
250 millions de dollars donc on est plus
du tout sur les mêmes ordres d'idées
donc il a besoin de lever de l'argent
auprès des petits donateurs et c'est
pour ça qu'il vient qu'il se montre
qu'il crie au scandale à la Kabbale au
complot etc et ça marche à tous les
coups on va parler de l'électorat Trump
évidemment longuement longuement dans ce
dans ce débat mais donc il apparaît il
dit je suis victime d'un complot
l'argent entre quoi il a des
inconditionnels donc ces inconditionnels
vont donner c'est d'ailleurs une
tradition de la vie politique américaine
que des petits donateurs donnent 20
dollars 50 dollars peut-être 100 dollars
à différents
n'est pas entamé c'est à dire que
peut-être que ça solvabilité va être
mise en cause mais son capital politique
pour le moment n'est pas du tout journal
votre avis là-dessus peut-être des
achelles et Jean-Claude beau jour juste
après sur le capital politique il est
quand même l'objet d'un certain nombre
d'attaque on l'a vu encore avec le
deuxième débat des primaires
républicaines récemment il a assisté
à nouveau mais il a été l'objet
d'attaque beaucoup plus nombreuses et
beaucoup plus nourries donc lors du
premier débat exactement et donc son
capital politique n'est pas entamé
auprès de ses inconditionnels eux ça ne
changera rien il y a un socle qui vote à
Trump quoi qu'il arrive mais il y a
aussi des électeurs modérés indépendants
qui sont encore hésitants et auprès
desquels il peut perdre du crédit
politique un mot mais rapide là-dessus
parce qu'on va y revenir un peu plus
tard je crois surtout que Donald Trump
ne répond pas à la question de fond j'ai
l'acte de poursuit effectivement il vous
dit procès politique
exercice etc il faut il faut lire l'acte
de poursuite donc c'est vrai que
lorsqu'on regarde un appartement évalué
acheter à 80 millions à un moment donné
en tout cas évalué à 90 millions qui
devient 327 millions de dollars les
éléments sont là jamais ils ne répond
sur le fond il répond sur la forme alors
à partir de ce moment-là le débat dans
l'opinion publique est complètement
déplacé et c'est ce qui fait que son
capital politique n'est pas atteint il
n'est pas atteint parce que ce sa base
reste la même il n'est pas atteint parce
qu'il n'y a pas aujourd'hui
d'alternative chez les républicains à
Donald Trump finalement il est dit un
tel écart aujourd'hui entre lui et les
suivants que finalement il conserve une
certaine dynamique je vous donne la
parole tout de suite un désigne c'est
promis mais je voudrais quand même qu'on
qu'on moi aussi je puisse apporter
quelques éléments au débat notamment on
parle d'un bras de fer médiatique et
juridique et entre Donald Trump
évidemment mais aussi donc Laetitia
James que vous avez cité procureur
général de l'État de New York tiens on
va les écouter tous les deux l'ancien
président pour commencer
pour faire simple c'est une chasse aux
sorcières c'est une honte nous avons une
procureur général corrompue vous verrez
ce qui se passera ce procès a fait
l'objet d'une procédure accélérée il
aurait pu être intenté il y a des années
mais ils ont attendu que je sois en
plein milieu de ma campagne il en va de
même pour d'autres procès et un
culpassion tout est organisé par le
ministère de la Justice qui est corrompu
à Washington
Donald Trump et les autres accusés ont
commis des fraudes continues et répétés
la semaine dernière nous l'avons prouvé
dans notre requête en référé aujourd'hui
nous allons prouver nos autres
accusations
on a commencé à en parler c'est est-ce
que c'est une adversaire politique pour
reprendre la rhétorique de Donald Trump
alors
Hitler que les deux les deux
responsables
d'État 3 sont des démocrates
donc elle est accusée d'être partiale
d'être l'ennemi d'avoir décidé d'avoir
sa peau etc celle-ci aussi est démocrate
et cela étant elle a lancé l'enquête
quand il y a eu suffisamment d'éléments
perturbants divulgués par Michael Cohen
donc l'avocat l'ancien avocat est fixeur
c'est lui qui était là dans tous les
mauvais coups c'est lui qui réparait
tous les pavés coups donc c'est sans
doute lui qui sait le plus comment le
pire Trump fonctionne en réalité qui
était au courant des doubles jeux
d'écriture les surévaluation parfois les
sous-évaluations de lorsqu'il s'agit de
payer donc
mais pour revenir à cette histoire
d'images il faut se rappeler quand même
vous visualisez tous en train de
descendre l'escalator de la Trump Tower
il s'est présenté comme le magna de
l'immobilier celui à qui tout réussi il
a des doigts d'or c'est un génie il a
fait fortune etc et là cette image elle
est très très atteinte il y a non
seulement le portefeuille dont je
parlais tout à l'heure mais il y a
l'image et ceux qui qui se projettent
d'entre eux les 40% qui feraient
n'importe quoi qui donne de l'argent qui
traverserait je sais pas une rivière
pleine de crocodiles pour lui ils sont
en train de se dire peut-être certains
d'entre eux va finalement il est
peut-être pas si bon que ça c'est
peut-être simplement un escroc c'est une
toute petite minorité mais nous sommes
peut-être aujourd'hui au début d'un
basculement il y a eu déjà le
basculement de l'establissement
républicain on voit bien mais peut-être
dans les 40% alors est-ce que ça sera
suffisant pour qu'il n'emporte pas
l'investiture républicaine c'est loin
d'être certain parce que ça commence
dans 3 mois
j'étais ado qu'on parlait déjà de Donald
Trump
Atlantic City donc c'est donc c'est vrai
il a toujours été sulfurieux les coups
bas au maire de New York c'est c'est un
génie du des coups il y a toujours été
sulfureux et pourtant ça continue à
fonctionner jusqu'à quand je vous le
concerne
que il devait gagner du temps il a usé
de manière
et là tout d'un coup il y a une sorte de
d'alignement des planètes la justice au
niveau fédéral au niveau de l'État a
décidé on arrête de jouer alors on va
parler évidemment on continue de parler
de l'électorat Trump Laetitia vous vous
posez la question de la permanence en
quelque sorte de cette Amérique qu'il a
élu président il y a 7 ans oui c'est la
question que vous avez posée finalement
vous avez commencé à la poser avant moi
cette Amérique que personne n'avait vu
venir Thomas en 2016 qui a élu Donald
Trump qui est passé en quelque sorte
sous tous les radars cette Amérique
est-ce qu'elle va continuer finalement
de faire l'élection en 2024 de voter
pour Trump et je pose la question parce
que avant que le procès ne commence hier
avant que les premières images justement
avant même la parole la prise de parole
de Donald Trump on a vu c'est un mec qui
V sur les marches du tribunal les deux
camps les pros et les anti Trump devant
les caméras donc le procès n'est pas
filmé déjà le spectacle entre les deux
camps se rejoue et ça nous donne quand
même un tout petit peu plus de si vous
voulez encore une fois d'illustration et
que ça concrétise cette Amérique qui est
vraiment division est-ce que c'est un
héritage de la présidence Trump oui
médias c'est saillie sur la Poste vérité
sur les faits alternatifs ça a vraiment
coupé en deux divisé en deux l'Amérique
et on a vu se dessiner les contours de
cette Amérique pro Trump une Amérique
finalement qui est captive de la
propagande populiste on aurait pu se
dire qu'après tous ces déboires vous
avez raison Madame judiciaire et puis
même politique on aurait pu se dire que
cette Amérique aurait renoncé et puis
aurait compris l'arnaque je reprends un
mot de Donald Trump l'arnaque Trump
vraisemblablement cette Amérique là même
si elle fait 40% continue de militer
pour son champion donc comment on peut
la définir est-ce qu'on peut la
simplifier en prenant en disant blanche
populaire par exemple c'est de cette
façon que les politologues ont
finalement parce que ça met du temps
pour qu'on a défini cette cette Amérique
ont finalement défini cette Amérique pro
Trump et ce qui est intéressant dans
cette pré-campagne américaine c'est que
c'est précisément cette Amérique que
vise aussi Joe Biden la classe ouvrière
blanche et ça c'est illustré par une
bataille finalement sur le terrain entre
Joe Biden et Donald Trump qui sont allés
voir les ouvriers grévistes de
l'industrie automobile les deux parce
que les deux savent que c'est là que se
joue la future élection et c'est pour
cette raison que je pose aujourd'hui la
question de de l'avenir de l'Amérique de
Donald Trump parce que Joe Biden lui
aussi a compris que c'était cette
Amérique là qu'il fallait séduire et ce
sera le combat des prochains mois pour
vous oui je crois que la question qui se
pose c'est est-ce que l'Amérique protrum
va basculer vers Joe Biden ce n'est pas
uniquement un enjeu américain ça l'est
évidemment de façon immédiate et
concrète mais ça l'est aussi c'est une
question de que doit se poser toutes les
démocraties
occidentales qui sont menacées ou
toucher directement par cette vague
populiste parce que si finalement le
contre Trump s'est Amérique là encore
une fois qui était passé sous tous les
radars bascule vers Joe Biden cela donne
un espoir ça veut dire que le populisme
ne serait pas une fatalité sauf que ça
va se jouer
ils achèvent sur évidemment à la sur les
marches sur plutôt sur les indécis vous
les avez commencé à l'évoquer mais quand
on regarde les sondages si on va
regarder un sondage ensemble qui nous
donne un c'est un sondage récent un
Washington Post et abyssinius sondage
publié à la fin du mois de septembre qui
donne un Donald Trump avec 52% des voix
face à Joe Biden 42% des voix c'est un
écart de 10 points qui était qui est
énorme il nous manque quoi il nous
manque un peu les indécis pour évaluer
les perspectives de cette campagne
électorale aujourd'hui
oui pour l'instant on voit différents
types de sondages on pourrait regarder
d'autres chiffres qui nous donnent
d'autres tendances ce qu'il y a deux
choses qui sont différentes par rapport
à 2016 la première chose c'est que
Donald Trump même si on le connaît dans
le paysage médiatique depuis 40 ans
n'est pas un primo-candidat c'est à dire
qu'il a déjà été au manège donc il ne
peut pas avoir la sentiment de certains
qui pourraient sais séduire au cas où
peut-être que donc il est déjà connu et
le deuxième élément il est lié à la
démographie de l'électorat il y a de
plus en plus de jeunes pour des raisons
strictement démographiques qui accèdent
aux droits de vote et ces jeunes sont
déjà arrivés dans les électorat en
partie en 2020 ils ont fait la
différence et là il y en aura encore
plus et on sait que ces jeunes vont
plutôt vers le Parti démocrate et ne
sont pas attirés par le Parti
républicain et certainement pas un
candidat comme Donald Trump donc l'enjeu
de ces élections à venir c'est
effectivement les modérés les
indépendants par exemple les femmes
autour de la question de l'avortement
les les syndiqués qui étaient les
piliers historiques du Parti démocrate
qui ont été un peu délaissés à la faveur
d'autres causes qui ont séduit les
catégories plus éduquées sur le racisme
systémique la défense des droits LGBT
etc donc c'est effectivement il y a un
enjeu autour de ces catégories peu
éduquer qui qui ont été délaissés par
partie de notre âge Jean-Claude bonjour
on a sous-estimé Donald Trump je mets
moi comme journaliste le les
observateurs notamment médiatiques lors
de sa première campagne personne l'a vu
unie on disait il va s'écraser il
remportera pas la primaire républicaine
ensuite il remportera pas l'élection
présidentielle bref je vais pas refaire
cette histoire mais est-ce qu'on ne
sous-estime pas encore aujourd'hui
l'attachement de de son électorat
finalement quand on se dit peut-être que
ça va basculer peut-être que finalement
il y a beaucoup plus d'indécis et je
reprends votre argument effectivement
maintenant on sait à quoi s'attendre moi
je crois que oui parce que son électorat
c'est effectivement les lectorat dont
vous avez parlé blanc populaire vous
avez aussi des gens qui sont
parfaitement éduqués et qui sont
intéressés par la personnalité de Donald
Trump vous avez toutes ces personnes qui
sont éduquées et qui croient là pour le
coup que le système de Washington est un
système corrompu moi j'ai rencontré cet
été pendant de longues semaines dans des
états très différents bien sûr dans le
centre américain mais aussi un peu sur
la côte Est où des gens vous expliquent
lorsqu'on reprenait avec des gens
vraiment bien éduqués en reprenant les
charges qui pesaient contre lui il vous
explique il vous disent mais vous savez
tout ça ce sont des c'est un système qui
de toutes les façons à la base et
corrompu donc le résultat que vous avez
est un résultat qui est pour nous
inopérant en tout cas ce sont de cette
mauvaise procès qui est fait Donald
Trump donc je pense qu'il faut aussi que
l'on se dise qu'il y a ce il y a pas que
des des gens qui sont des laissés pour
compte ou la populaire ça c'est le
premier point et puis il y a un second
point qu'il a pour le coup ne concerne
pas que la mairie de mes concerne avant
tout l'Amérique je crois que la la
polarisation est un élément qui est qui
a commencé pour le coup avant Donald
Trump et Donald Trump a fait que surfé
sur cette vague et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on n'a pas vu venir c'est que
la fracture existait il a peut-être
accentué mais c'est pas le seul pays où
elle est simplement qu'on se dit c'est
Donald Trump qui a non Donald Trump il a
profité il a très bien compris parce
qu'avant il était démocrate quand même
il a très bien compris qu'il pouvait
surfer sur cette sur cette vague là ça
c'est la première chose et puis la
deuxième chose qui concerne probablement
toutes les démocraties il y a un certain
nombre d'études de sciences politiques
tout à fait intéressante par de grands
chercheurs américains non-américains qui
commencent à se dire au fond si nous en
sommes à ce stade où les populistes
peuvent arriver au pouvoir dans de
nombreux États c'est parce que la
démocratie n'a pas été au rendez-vous
des promesses des promesses qui ont été
qui ont été qui a été faites par le
système donc ça c'est un sujet un niveau
pour l'Amérique évidemment l'Amérique
est une caisse de résonance de par sa
taille et parce que c'est c'est la
première puissance du monde mais c'est
un sujet qui vaut aussi en Europe c'est
un sujet et qui peut expliquer un
certain nombre de fractures à travers la
planète on reste sur si vous louez bien
des unes sur cette électorat trumpiste
on reviendra effectivement un peu plus
aux affaires judiciaires et notamment à
celle qui touche de Biden puisque il y
avait coïncidence du calendrier il y a
aussi le feast byden qui est qui est
jugé aujourd'hui donc on y reviendra un
peu plus tard dans ce débat mais la part
de du complotisme ou des vérités
alternatives pour reprendre pour
reprendre une sémantique de Trump dans
dans la sa capacité à capter et à garder
cet électorat quelle part vous donner à
ce à ce mouvement alors déjà tout ce que
fait Trump effectivement je suis
d'accord ça s'inscrit dans un long passé
il y a eu un tournant important 1994
quand nude qui ingridge a fait campagne
pour le fameux contrat avec la mairie
c'est lui qui a dit faut qu'on change
les règles du jeu les démocrates ce sont
plus des adversaires ce sont des ennemis
avec une touche de racisme mais tout
était un petit peu sous-jacent ça
restait honteux et Trump à tous
légitimer donc tout ceci sort et donc
maintenant cela permet à toutes les
théories du complot de dire les pires
horreurs avec la caisse de résonance des
médias sociaux je pense que une des
choses qu'il faut vraiment avoir en tête
pour cette campagne électorale c'est
qu'elle va se dérouler dans un climat de
désinformation totale
parce que Fox News qui a pourtant du
pays 787 de mémoire millions de dollars
dans le procès en diffamation intenté
par le fabricant de machines à voter
dominium du bout des lettres à dit oui
peut-être nous n'avons pas été
totalement
exacts
invité des gens qui parlaient de fraude
eux-mêmes parler de fraude d'élection
volée alors que dans la procédure de
Discovery dans la première étape d'un
procès le juge à regarder tous les
échanges de mails et on a constaté que
Murdoch et les journalistes savaient
parfaitement que Joe Biden avait gagné
et que malgré tout il continuait donc
Fox News a été dû payer cette somme
assez importante quand même près d'un
milliard de dollars mais les
journalistes continuent de mentir et
surtout les réseaux sociaux et alors
vous n'avez peut-être pas suivi mais il
y a eu deux affaires en justice devant
la Cour suprême où se poser la question
de la section 230 de la loi sur la
communication cette section elle dit
lorsqu'on est plateforme aux réseaux
sociaux on est simplement hébergeur donc
on n'a pas de responsabilité donc il y a
une immunité une irresponsabilité
juridique totale et donc il est
impossible de poursuivre les morceaux je
de Trump parce que premièrement de faire
changer Fox et encore plus ou encore
moins de changer les réseaux sociaux et
par conséquent tous ces complots toutes
ces contre-vérités nous allons en avoir
des quantités alors de temps en temps il
y aura malheureusement
que les mensonges ne sont jamais
rectifiés les lecteurs ils gardent dans
la tête le premier mensonge
on parlait de la caisse de résonance
médiatique de ce procès et des autres
puisque on a d'autres qui vont rythmer
en quelque sorte la campagne
présidentielle de de Donald Trump je
comprends bien les leviers que ça lui
permet d'activer levier médiatique
levier financier puisque ça ça provoque
des loyers de fond mais est-ce que pour
vous la posture de victime parce que
c'est de la posture qu'il choisi elle
n'a pas quand même aussi ses limites si
bien sûr d'ailleurs on l'a vu avec la
lecture des chefs d'accusation dans le
procès de Géorgie il n'était pas là et
il a usé son droit à ne pas comparaître
donc
quelques mots
il fait pression il essaye de 700 voix
négociés par téléphone
ça les récupérer vive la démocratie
donc en fait cette posture de victime il
en joue comme sur une partition
c'est-à-dire que parfois il va insister
sur ce point là d'autres fois il va se
mettre plus en retrait et éviter la
médiatisation donc là sur ce process
civile il peut se mettre un petit peu
plus en avant parce que c'est quand même
moins grave d'un point de vue politique
pas d'un point de vue financier mais
d'un point de vue politique c'est quand
même moins grave que ce qu'il attend
concernant cette affaire de Géorgie et
concernant l'invasion du Capitole qui
sera jugé à partir de mars donc il joue
en fait de cette de cette posture en
fonction des moments est-ce que ça peut
lui rapporter à la fois politiquement et
financièrement il a tout intérêt juste
pour en communication politique on ne
change jamais une stratégie qui a
fonctionné au départ il y a tout intérêt
à vraiment utiliser ce capital de
victime et d'image jusqu'au bout parce
que sinon ça vient aussi une stratégie
judiciaire soit vous décidez de jouer la
victime et d'éviter le débat de fond et
si vous allez sur le débat de fond il
est évident quand on voit il faut lire
l'acte d'accusation que vous voyez les
entretiens téléphoniques où il dit tu
sais qu'il me manque 11000 voix tu sais
qu'il me manque 11000 voix donc on sait
très bien qu'il fait pression il y a pas
moyen d'expliquer ça et les juristes le
savent d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour
laquelle son avocat Giuliani est
embarqué aussi dans cette histoire parce
que tout au long de la soirée électorale
et un peu après ils ont continué à dire
il y a eu fraude etc et la justice a dit
mais non vous ne le saviez bien et vous
avez vous êtes allés au-delà de ce scoop
donc vous lui dites il y a les éléments
factuels enfin bon voilà donc s'ils
viennent sur le fond ils sont quasiment
sûr de perdre donc ça explique la
stratégie
de choses lui nous vous entrez dans le
fond du dossier moi je veux bien dans
les 242 pages de vous regarder le
dossier vous devez expliquer comment
vous passez de 80 millions à 327 en
l'espace de 3 vous revenez au processus
et vous devez expliquer comment est-ce
que même appartenant à voix sa surface
multiplié par trois ou quatre alors là
c'est un des rares où il y a une vague
défense juridiques c'est à dire les
avocats de Trump ont trois arguments
première argument ils disent de toute
façon les évaluations c'est jamais très
très précis deuxièmement ils disent en
première page il y a un disclaimer c'est
à dire un une sorte de
d'exonération de responsabilité qui dit
nos chiffres il ne faut pas trop s'y
fier et l'accusation
est rédigé en termes assez vague sauf
que quand Trump en parle devant les les
télévisions il dit ça dit c'est plein de
mensonges ne vous y fiez pas il y a pas
du tout ça dans le disquemment une autre
chose sur le plan juridique les avocats
de Trump disent toute façon il y a
prescription parce qu'il y a eu une
décision il y a une décision d'un juge
d'appel mais de toute façon même si il y
a prescription le juge va étudier les
fraudes de 2014 à 2023 il reste de quoi
faire et dernière élément mis en avant
par les avocats de Trump ils disent mais
aucune banque n'a perdu de l'argent il
n'y a pas de préjudice or la loi de New
York ne demande pas de préjudice dès
lors qu'il y a mensonge qu'il y a fraude
on peut sanctionner un exemple qu'on
donne que tous les avocats donnent c'est
vous prenez un pistolet vous cherchez à
tuer quelqu'un vous le ratez on va quand
même vous poursuivre parce que vous avez
essayé même chose pour la foudre si vous
prenez l'acte l'acte de poursuite à la
page 76 il y a un appartement qui passe
en jeudi en square fit de 30000 et qui
était de
c'est la superficie ça c'est voilà sur
la superficie ça fait combien c'est
superficie donc c'est x 3 donc alors
un truc que personne n'a vu ici quoi
c'est ça d'accord mais c'est pour vous
dire trois fois trois fois plus il y a
une grosse il y a une grosse différence
et donc là vous avez du mal lorsque vous
êtes avocat vous avez du mal à surmonter
à remonter ce type il y a une question
que je me pose depuis le début de cette
affaire parce que donc il a surévalué le
son empire et notamment c'est bien
immobilier sauf qu'on paye des impôts
sur le fait avouer ce que je veux dire
on paye des impôts sur sur ces biens
immobiliers donc j'ai pas qu'il y a
cette logique qui m'échappe je comprends
bien que ça l'a aidé à négocier avec les
banques avec les assurances etc sauf que
ce qu'il a gagné d'un côté ce qui risque
pas de le perdre de l'autre avec les
impôts alors on peut jouer j'étais pas
parti à l'accord je pense que si
finalement il a pensé que c'était bien
de surévaluer
par rapport à la loi fiscale
il a forcément fait un calcul c'est à
dire que Trump est quand même habitué
des deals en business ça fait 40 ans
qu'il est là dedans il a eu d'ailleurs
de nombreux procès dans le cadre de ces
entreprises et nombreux procès aussi
villes rappelons-nous que l'affaire
stormy Daniels
[Musique]
mais surtout ce qui lui était reproché
c'est d'avoir falsifié les contes de ces
entreprises donc il est habitué à ces
tripatoyage si je puis dire donc
forcément il a fait son calcul avant
d'ailleurs c'est l'un des arguments de
de ces avocats de dire bah attendez
c'est du business quoi c'est pas c'est
pas très surprenant c'est du business
alors il me semble me rappeler que
lorsque Michael Cohen donc toujours le
fixer à témoigner et il a dit que Trump
n'avait pas les mêmes chiffres lorsqu'il
s'agissait de dire la valeur pour
solliciter un emprunt et lorsqu'il
s'agissait de payer les impôts
non mais grosso modo bien sûr le premier
réflexe mais l'ancien président était
suffisamment équipé Théo entouré il y a
c'est beaucoup plus subtil que cela mais
évidemment qu'il est il était conseillé
qu'il y a des gens qui ont qui ont fait
tout ce qu'il fallait pour que tantôt il
pue il puisse sûr tantôt il puisse
sous-évaluer c'était c'est relativement
classique ensuite on parle de de Joe
Biden mais quand même une autre question
parce que on va rappeler on a fait un
débat autour de notre pierre il y a
quelques semaines ici même et je vais
redonner des éléments pour se présenter
à la présentiel américaine il faut être
âgé d'au moins 35 ans né aux États-Unis
avoir résidé aux États-Unis pendant au
moins 14 ans mais mais on peut être en
pleine poursuite pénale en plein procès
voire même être en prison et on rappelle
régulièrement l'histoire d'un socialiste
qui avait été condamné et qui a mené sa
campagne présidentielle derrière les
barreaux c'était dans les années 1920
en désigne dans l'absolu il pourrait
mener campagne derrière les barreaux ça
n'arrivera pas bref mais en revanche il
y a quand même certains juristes
américains qui affirment que l'ancien
président ne peut pas concourir il
s'appuie sur le 14e amendement de la
Constitution américaine est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi et dans
quel cadre de de procès on est oui c'est
même la section 3 du 14e amendement qui
dit que lorsque on a prêté serment de
défendre la Constitution et que l'on
commet des crimes contre la Constitution
contre l'État que l'on forme des
insurrections on ne peut pas être
candidat donc il y a un certain nombre
de personnes qui se disent que peut-on
faire de ce 14e amendement sauf que la
mise en oeuvre de la section 3 n'est pas
si facile alors il y a un état je crois
que c'est le Colorado qui a inventé une
action en justice en disant nous ne
pourrons pas l'inscrire sur les
bulletins à cause du 14e amendement
section 3 mais en fait est-ce que par
exemple les bureaux de vote doivent
rayer son nom en disant non non 14e
amendement il y a pas mal d'articles qui
ont été écrits par ceux qui sont
spécialistes de sujets qui disent que ça
existe effectivement mais que la mise en
oeuvre sera très difficile et qu'en fait
il y a très peu de chances qu'on puisse
s'appuyer sur ce 14e amendement en
d'autres termes on va revenir à l'impact
des décisions judiciaires sur les
lecteurs est-ce que va faire les
lecteurs en dernier
faut que il soit reconnu qu'obéillant
porté atteinte à la à la Constitution
américaine pour l'instant nous en sommes
au procès et que juridiquement il n'est
pas encore condamné de manière définie
oui oui et ces avocats vont essayer
évidemment faire traîner plus possible
allez on s'intéresse maintenant à la
campagne de Joe Biden et au procès qui
frappe son fils Hunter Biden il
comparaissait aujourd'hui pour une
affaire de détention d'illégale illégale
d'armes à feu je propose à Quentin calmé
de nous rejoindre bonsoir Quentin
bienvenue à vous sur ce plateau des
faits qui remontent à 2018 exactement le
fils du président américain actuel
plaide non coupable dans ce dossier ce
que lui ce qui lui reproche exactement
c'est d'avoir menti en remplissant des
documents officiels pour l'acquisition
de son arme à feu il n'aurait pas
mentionné son addiction à certaines
drogues comme le crack à l'époque en
2018 Hunter Biden a parlé de ses
problèmes d'addiction à l'alcool et aux
drogues dans un ouvrage ce sont ses
aveux qui leur attrapent aujourd'hui
enterbidden risque gros dans ce dossier
il encourt jusqu'à 25 ans de prison même
si les rares de voir de telles affaires
se solder par des peines aussi lourdes
le fils du client américain qui est
également
en cause dans d'autres dossiers oui
notamment de fraudes fiscales mais les
élus républicains au Congrès accusent
même Hunter Biden d'avoir fait des
affaires dans des conditions troubles
avec l'Ukraine et la Chine les élus pro
Trump qui vont très loin dans leurs
accusations on a vu certains de ces élus
républicains brandir au sein même du
Congrès américain des photos
compromettantes de Hunter Biden pas mal
d'arguments assez outranciers au passage
ses élus qui ont des opinions très
controversées sur la vaccination par
exemple certains de ces parlementaires
comme cette élu de l'État de Géorgie
relais des théories complotistes ils ont
même donc lancé une procédure de
destitution contre le président
américain persuadé que l'administration
a couvert le fils de Joe Biden de son
côté la Maison Blanche assure que le
président américain n'a rien fait de mal
je cite écouter la porte-parole de la
Maison Blanche Karine Jean-Pierre
les républicains du Congrès ont passé
toute l'année à enquêter sur le
Président c'est ce qu'ils ont fait toute
l'année et ils l'ont trouvé aucune
preuve aucune qui les fait quoi que ce
soit de mal
en fait les républicains visent Hunter
byden car ils ont trouvé là un talon
d'Achille du président démocrate la vie
de famille de Joe Biden a été marquée
par plusieurs drames la mort de sa
première femme et de sa première fille
en 1972 la mort de son fils aîné beau
Biden décédé d'un cancer du cerveau en
2015 le père veut protéger son dernier
fils coûte que coûte écoutez cet extrait
du interview en mai dernier aux médias
MSNBC écouter
il y a quelque chose qui vous touche
personnellement votre fils sans que cela
est un lien avec vous pourrez être
poursuivi par votre ministère de la
justice qu'elle peut être l'impact sur
votre mandat de président mon fils n'a
rien fait de mal je lui fais confiance
j'ai foi en Lui et l'impact sur ma
présidence c'est que je suis fier de lui
en tout cas cette enquête parlementaire
qui a été voulue par les élus
républicains elle n'a aucune chance
d'aller au bout mais elle vient rendre
un peu plus délétère encore le débat
politique américain très tendu à
Washington en ce moment merci beaucoup
Quentin Anne désigne à quel point cette
affaire peut ou pas d'ailleurs plomber
la campagne de Joe Biden tout d'abord ce
que les républicains cherchent à faire
c'est faire une équivalence il n'y a
rien à voir entre tous les crimes toutes
les horreurs de Trump et d'autres petits
délits de Biden parce que ce qui est
poursuivi c'est pas grand chose vous
voyez on veut dire ce qu'il a fait et
qui n'est pas bien c'est de profiter du
nom de son papa pour gagner des millions
de dollars avec les Chinois par exemple
les Ukrainiens mais ce n'est pas ça qui
est en jeu ce qui est en jeu dans le
procès c'est le fait qu'il n'a pas payé
ses impôts pendant 2 ans il les a payé
après et ce n'est même pas un délit
c'est une contravention pas grand chose
et l'autre chose c'est qu'il a menti
pour acheter une arme à feu il a dit
qu'il ne prenait pas de drogue alors
qu'il en prenait
c'est un délit qui n'est jamais
poursuivi pratiquement mettons une fois
sur un million et qui ne donne presque
jamais lieu à des peines de prison donc
on a les républicains qui en sont
cantonnés à instrumentaliser ces deux
petites choses cela étant ça ne va pas
aider la campagne de Biden qui est très
fin dans les sondages et surtout ça le
touche affectivement parce que il a
toujours été très proche de ces deux
fils après le drame qui a été rappelé et
ça c'est le fils à problème c'est pas le
héros comme beau qui s'est drogué qui
avait le Joe Biden a toujours été à ses
côtés vous avez peut-être remarqué il y
a quelques mois enter Biden est revenu
dans on le voyait sur les photos il a
fait des voyages avec son père il
descendait la passerelle des forces one
avec son père et je pense que Joe Biden
espérait qu'il allait pouvoir revenir
alors peut-être pas le conseiller mais
être à ses côtés l'aider à faire
campagne et ça tant que le procès tant
que l'hypothèque n'est pas levé ce n'est
pas possible cela étant il y a un
premier plaid coupable une première
reconnaissance de culpabilité bon qui
est tombée à l'eau il y a quelques mois
il y aura peut-être une deuxième
reconnaissance de culpabilité avec peine
minimale pour un jobiden ce qui
permettrait de clôturer l'affaire sera
terminée
à établir le moindre lien les raisons
entre le fils et le père le père de ses
parents ici le père n'a rien fait il
nous reste à les trois minutes dans ce
dans ce débat j'aurais qu'on parle quand
même de la campagne de de Joe Biden
elisachète est-ce que c'est le meilleur
candidat démocrate ce qu'on peut se dire
quand même il va avoir il aura 82 ans en
novembre 2024 au moment où les
Américains voteront 86 ans s'il est
réduit est-ce que c'est le meilleur
candidat on sait quand même qu'il y a
des problèmes cognitifs hyper la mémoire
enfin bon c'est et c'est c'est
pratiquement toutes les mois il y a une
image de Joe Biden qu'on voit affaibli
quoi alors tout dépend du référentiel
dans lequel on se place parce
qu'effectivement Joe Biden et
physiquement et cognitivement affaibli
je pense qu'il en a donné des des
preuves à plusieurs reprises mais il
faut voir où on est le Parti démocrate
et quels sont les alternatives possibles
d'ailleurs Joe Biden concède assez
facilement qu'il n'est pas le meilleur
mais qu'il est l'alternative à Donald
Trump donc les autres candidats
démocrates sont loin en termes de
notoriété d'assise politique
d'expérience et c'est la force pardon
nous interrompre c'est la force de
l'habitude c'est à dire qu'un candidat
un président sortant représente
forcément et donc ça éteint les les
autres candidats ou candidats de
potentiel et puis il pourrait y avoir
aussi une stratégie de la part du camp
Biden puisqu'il repart en ticket avec
kamalaharis qui il a beaucoup soutenu
enfin ils se sont beaucoup soutenus
pendant cette ce premier mandat
Biden lui a confié des dossiers
importants mais kamalaris n'est pas
parvenu à transformer l'essai en quelque
sorte et gagner en popularité à
s'imposer comme sa successeur au Parti
démocrate donc là il l'emmène dans son
ticket ce qui veut dire que si il arrive
à aller au bout de la campagne et dans
l'hypothèse ou des réélu ça pourrait
être kamalaris qui prendrait le relais
prochainement
il y a quelqu'un qui est le gouverneur
de Californie parce que vous avez
peut-être remarqué que une sénatrice est
morte dans une french time et donc il
incombe au gouverneur de Californie de
nommer celui ou celle qui va remplir la
fin de mandat
il a choisi quelqu'un de très politique
mais qui n'est pas un des trois
candidats déjà en lice pour succéder à
Darren Stein qui de toute façon avait
dit qu'elle se représentait pas la vie
90 ans donc quand même c'est à peu près
normal et il apparaît beaucoup et il va
en particulier participer à un débat
avec Rouen de santé le gouverneur de
Floride sans doute avec la bénédiction
de la Maison Blanche donc certains
disent qu'il y a une prise de conscience
à la Maison Blanche que s'il arrive
quelque chose à Biden kamilaaris n'est
pas nécessairement la bonne candidate et
les autres parce qu'il y en a qui sont
très bons il y a des chouchous à moi
pitbu DJ ministre des Transports la
gouvernance
l'école bleue et les Noirs seul Biden
pour le moment peut le faire
de ne pas vous avoir comme aller à Harry
se fait beaucoup et se remuent beaucoup
depuis cet été parce qu'elle sent bien
qu'il y a peut-être quelque chose à
jouer et qui va falloir qu'elle trouve
sa place définitivement effectivement
merci à tous je rappelle le titre de
votre livre un désigne les États-Unis et
la démocratie publie aux éditions
l'Harmattan a très bientôt sur sur
public